Welcome to our video on devops engineer
interview questions devops has become an
essential skill set for today's
technology professionals with many
organizations seeking out talented
individuals who can help them build and
maintain their infrastructure if you are
looking to become a devops engineer this
video is for you in this video we'll be
covering some of the most common
interview questions for devops engineer
as well as some tips on how to answer
them successfully we will cover
infrastructure as code and CI CD
pipelines along with many other
important topics you'll often be asked
about your experience with Isa tools
like terraform and ansible as well as
your knowledge of cloud providers like
AWS Google cloud or Microsoft Azure we
will also discuss tools like Jenkins
Travis Ci or Circle CI as well as
concepts of containerization and
kubernetes there's a lot to learn and a
lot to discuss in our devops engineer
interview questions video so without any
further Ado let's get started also if
you are Keen to learn more about devops
and its Concepts and want to attain a
job in A Renault company then simply
learns Caltech postgraduate program in
devops can be the right choice for you
this comprehensive program will equip
you with the knowledge and skills needed
to master the devops principles tools
and practices so dive deep into
containerization orchestration and
automation framework like Docker
kubernetes and Jenkins gain hands-on
experience with Cloud platforms and
learn how to Leverage The Power of
infrastructure as code so don't miss out
on this chance to transform your career
and become unvaluable asset to any
organization click the link in the
description to discover more about this
devops course now let's jump into the
video but before moving ahead let's
first understand what is devops now
devops is a set of activities and
approaches aimed at enhancing the
effectiveness and Excellence of software
development delivery and deployment it
brings together the Realms of software
development depth and information
technology operations Ops the main goal
of devops is to encourage seamless
collaboration between development and
operations team throughout the entire
software development life cycle it
achieves this through the utilization of
automation continuous integration
delivery and deployment thereby
accelerating the process and minimizing
errors in software develop now let's
explore who is a devops engineer now a
devops engineer is an expert in
developing deploying and maintaining
software systems using devops practices
they work closely with it operations
developers and stakeholders to ensure
efficient software delivery the
responsibilities include implementing
automation continuous integration and
continuous delivery or deployment
practices as well as resolving issues
throughout the deployment process devops
Engineers are proficient in various
tools and Technologies such as source
code Management Systems build and
deployment tools virtualization and
container Technologies but how exactly
to become a devops engineer now
depending on the business and the
individual function different criteria
for becoming a devops engineer may exist
however some specific fundamental skills
and certifications are frequently needed
or recommended first is an excellent
technical background now devops
Engineers should be well versed in it
operations system administration and
software development second is
experience with devops tools and
methodologies now devops Engineers
should have experience with various
devops Technologies and processes
including Version Control Systems build
and deployment automation
containerization cloud computing and
monitoring and logging tools third is
scripting and automation skills not
devops Engineers should have strong
scripting skills and be proficient in
using tools such as bus python or
Powershell to automate tasks and
processes for this cloud computing
experience now devops Engineers should
have experience working with Cloud
platforms such as Amazon web services
Microsoft Azure or Google Cloud platform
and in the end certification some
organization may require devops
Engineers to hold relevant
certifications such as certified devops
engineer CDE or certified kubernetes
administrator cka or AWS certified
devops engineer professional well now
let us begin with some really important
devops interview questions and answers
as we have already covered the roadmap
of how to become a devops engineer so
the first question that we are coming up
with is how is devops different from
agile methodology well devops is a
culture that allows the development and
the operation team to work together this
result in continuous development testing
integration deployment and monitoring of
software throughout the life cycle
whereas agile is a software development
methodology that focuses on iterative
incremental small and Rapid Release of
software along with customer feedback
basically IT addresses gaps and
conflicts between the customer and
developers devops addresses gaps and
conflicts between the developers and IIT
operations now the second question is
which are some of the most popular
devops tools well some of the most
popular devops tools include selenium
puppet Chef get Jenkins ansible and
Docker which are considered really
important in today's world if you want
to become a successful devops engineer
third question is what is the difference
between continuous delivery and
continuous deployment now we will
address this one by one so continuous
delivery ensures that you can safely
deploy onto production but continuous
deployment ensure that every chain that
passes through automation testing that
is deployed to production automatically
instead of manually continuous delivery
ensures business applications are
delivered as they were expected now
continuous deployment makes sure that
software development and other processes
like release are smooth and faster
continuously we also make changes to a
production life environment through
rigorous automated testing but when it
comes to continuous deployment there is
no explicit approval for a developer to
require a developed culture question
four is what is the role of
configuration Management in devops now
configuration management enables
management of and changes to multiple
systems also it standardizes resource
configuration which in turn manage it
infrastructure also it helps with the
administration and management of
multiple servers and maintains the
Integrity of the entire infrastructure
next is what is the role of AWS in
devops well AWS has the following role
in devops first is flexible services
this provides ready-to-use flexible
services without the need to install or
set up the software second is build for
scale you can manage a single instance
or scale to thousands using AWS Services
third is automation AWS lets you
automate tasks and processes giving you
more time to innovate then come secure
using AWS identity and access management
you can set user permissions and
policies in your organization and then
come large partner ecosystem AWS
supports a large ecosystem of partners
that integrate with an extend AWS
Services now if we talk about the sixth
question that is name three important
devops kpi eyes now the three very
important kpis are as follows mean time
to failure recovery this is the average
time taken to recover from a failure
deployment frequency the frequency in
which the deployment occurs percentage
of failed deployments the number of
times the deployment fails now the
seventh question is what are the
benefits of using Version Control here
are some of the benefits of using
Version Control well all team members
are free to work on any file at any time
with the Version Control System later on
VCS will allow the team to integrate all
of the modifications into a single
version the VCS asked to provide a brief
summary of what was changed every time
we save a new version of the project we
also get to examine exactly what was
modified in the content of the file as a
result we will be able to see who made
what changes to the projects now inside
the VCS all the previous variants and
versions are properly stored we will be
able to request any version at any
moment and we will be able to retrieve a
snapshot of the entire project at our
fingertips a VCS that is distributed
such as git let all the team members
retrieve a completely history of the
project this allows developers or other
stakeholders to use to local git
repositories of any of the teammates
even if the main server goes down at any
point in time so the next question is
what is the blue green deployment
pattern now this is a method of
continuous deployment that is commonly
used to reduce downtime this is where
traffic is transformed from one instance
to another in order to include a fresh
version of the code we must replace the
code with the new code version the new
version exists in a green environment
and the old version exists in a blue
environment now after making changes to
the previous version we need a new
instance from the old one to execute a
newer version of the instance so this
was the right answer next is what is
continuous testing continuous testing
constitutes of running of automated test
as part of the software delivery
pipeline to provide instant feedback on
the business risk present in the most
recent release in order to prevent
problems in Step switching in the
software delivery life cycle and to
allow development teams to receive
immediate feedback every build is
continually tested in this manner now
this results in a significant increase
in speed in a developer's productivity
as it eliminates the requirement of
re-running all the tests after each
update and project rebuilding now let's
move to the next question that is what
is automation testing now test
automation or manual testing automation
is the process of automating a manual
procedure in order to test an
application or system automation testing
entails the use of independent testing
tools that allow you to develop test
scripts that can be run repeatedly
without the need for human interaction
next question is how to automate testing
in devops lifecycle now developers are
obliged to commit all the source code
changes to a shared devops repository
every time A change is made in the code
Jenkins like continuous integration
tools will will grab it from this common
repository and deploy it for continuous
testing which is done by tools like
selenium so why is continuous testing
important for devops any modification to
the code may be tested immediately with
continuous testing this prevents
concerns like quality issues and
releases delays that might occur
whenever big Bank testing is delayed
until the end of the cycle in this way
continuous testing allows for high
quality and more frequent releases so
next question is how do you push a file
from your local system to the GitHub
repository using git now first connect
the local repository to your remote
repository now git remote add origin and
then you can see the code and the Second
Step that you need to do is push your
file to the remote repository next
question is what is the process for
reverting a commit that has already been
pushed and made public now there are two
ways that you can revert a commit remove
or fix the bad file in a new comment and
push it to the remote repository then
commit it to the remote repository using
this command and second is create a new
comment that undoes all the changes that
were made in the bad commit you can use
this command for it next is explain the
difference between git Fetch and git
pull now git fetch only downloads new
data from a report repository whereas
git pull updates current head Branch
with the latest changes from the remote
server second difference is gitfish does
not integrate any new data into working
files whereas get pulled downloads new
data and integrates it with the current
working files get fetch users can run a
git fetch at any time to update the
remote tracking branches whereas git
pull tries to merge remote changes with
your local ones now coming to the next
question explain the concept of
branching in git suppose you are working
on an application and you want to add a
new feature to the app you can create a
new branch and build a new feature on
that Branch by default you always work
on the master branch and the circles on
the branch represent various comments
made on the branch so after you are done
with all the changes you can merge it
with the master Branch next question is
explain the Master Slave architecture of
Jenkins now Jenkins Master pulls the
code from the remote GitHub repository
every time there is a code commit it
distributes the workload to all the
Jenkins layers and when requested from
the Jenkins Master the slaves carry out
build test and produce test reports now
next question is which file is used to
Define dependency in maven
bill.xml pom dot XML
dependency.xml or version.xml well the
correct answer is perm dot XML next
question that we are going to cover is
explain the two types of pipelines in
Jenkins along with their syntax now
Jenkins provides two ways of developing
a pipeline code scripted and declarative
now scripted pipeline is based on groovy
script as their domain specific language
one or more note blocks do the core work
throughout the entire pipeline now the
syntax is execute the pipeline or any of
its stages on any available agent Define
the build stage perform steps related to
building stage now Define the test stage
perform steps related to this test stage
and Define the deploy stage and perform
steps related to the deploy stage now
declarative pipeline provides a simple
and friendly syntax to define a pipeline
here the pipeline block defines the work
done throughout the pipeline so the
syntax follows is first execute the
pipeline or any of its stage on any
available agent Define the build stage
perform steps related to building stage
then Define these test stage perform
stages related to the test stage Define
the deploy stage and perform steps
related to the deploy stage well this
was the code for declarative Pipeline
and the last question for this video is
explain how you can set up a Jenkins job
to create a Jenkins job we go to the top
page of Jenkins choose the new job
option and then select build a freestyle
software project now the elements of
this freestyle job are optional triggers
for controlling when Jenkins bills
option steps for Gathering data from the
build like collecting javadoc testing
results and or or archiving artifacts a
build script that actually does the work
or the optional source code management
system like subversion or CBS well there
you go these are some of the most common
devops interviewed questions that you
might come across while attending an
interview as a devops engineer in-depth
knowledge of processes tools and
relevant Technologies essential and
these devops interview questions and
answers will help you get some knowledge
about some of these aspects in addition
you must also have a holistic
understanding of the products services
and systems in place also here's an
inspiring success story from one of our
satisfied Learners who have propelled
their careers with devops this can help
you boost your confidence make a firm
decision in this field do watch it my
whole life here I started my ID Journey
with Accenture three years ago I joined
there as a cloud architect there I
worked with AWS and Azure Technologies
anyway looking for higher paying job and
devops seem the right career choice so I
decided to go with the postgraduate
program in devops in collaboration with
Caltech ctme course was divided into
modules
and we had assignments I was really
impressed by how many job interviews I
landed after I added the certification
to my portfolio and now I am earning 40
more than my previous job didn't only
boost my career but also my confidence
well this was all about this video If
you like this video then please do give
it a thumbs up and share it with your
friends also if you have any question
then please feel free to ask away in the
comment section our team will reach out
to you as soon as possible thank you and
keep learning
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
foreign
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learning YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here